I don't know if you can be less afraid
of death exactly but I think that here's
a hypothesis and this is a Socratic
hypothesis I write about this in my book
too by the way maybe if you live your
life thoroughly thoroughly right you
take use of the advantages make use of
the advantages that are put in front of
you make use of your talents say yes to
things tell the truth like stand up and
get out it assuming that you can do that
you know because some people are very
ill and and hurt and but assuming you
can do that I think the only way to
combat fear of death is to live fully
and I think that that might actually
work I I kind of wonder I've talked
about this with my father - who's
getting pretty old you know I've asked
him if for example if he could be
transformed back into an 18 year old
knowing what he knows now would he do it
and he was ambivalent about that you
know he didn't say no but he didn't say
yes and we talked about this idea that
if you lived your life fully you know
maybe that would be good enough because
you know I loved having kids but I don't
feel that I would have kids again you
know because in some sense I've already
done that and so maybe there's a set
number of adventures that you have to go
on in your life let's say you have to be
married you have to have kids you have
to have a career you have to have
friends you have to have something
useful to do with your time outside of
work all those are all things that are
covered in the future authoring program
by the way maybe if you do all those
it's like that's good enough you've had
your life and and that's enough I mean I
don't know ten years ago I thought you
know if I could extend my life radically
then I would and I'm not so sure about
that now then I'm I'm 55 you know I'm
getting older I kind of have a suspicion
that you might come to an end you know
that's what it looks like I mean I don't
want that to be soon but maybe you
exhaust
yourself in your life you know maybe you
can so that there's nothing left of you
really